let me bring in Chris Mannix this will
calm me down
hey Mannix how are you hey Dan have you
looked at this list do you care about
this list not especially but listening
to what you're saying I'm sure I'll
disagree because I mean look no
disrespect to the Russell's and you know
the rigged batteries and the guys that
played in that era and you could
certainly argue that if they were if
they benefit from the training of
today's game they'd be different in more
improved players but you're gonna tell
me that Rick Barry had any shot at doing
anything with Russell Westbrook like no
way like Russell Westbrook would eat him
alive in any competition possible well
no we're not playing one-on-one here
what are you talking about if that was
the I mean Kareem would win this because
he would back everybody down and score
over them okay it's not one-on-one well
I dispute that too I didn't like okay
like Kareem
there's ways of winning 101 but that's
Edie I agree with you okay but like do
you remember Russell Westbrook did that
first MVP MVP year like that team was
bad and you know Russell Westbrook went
out and propelled under like 43 44 wins
after losing you know arguably the best
player in the game you know will
certainly won the top three in Kevin
Durant I mean that's a pretty impressive
team accomplishment dad like to have a
look at the Golden State Warriors when
they won the NBA title Chris if we're
gonna make this about Rick berry and
Russell Westbrook
Russell Westbrook hasn't accomplished
anything other than a average a
triple-double
okay great he did it a couple of times
great if that's the case James Harden is
one of the top 15 players
I got Durant belongs up there Russell
Westbrook is a phenomenon but he's one
of the great players of all time that
he's better than Rick berry is silly it
is it's silly you think it's like
plopped Russell Westbrook on to those
Rick berry teams they'd be worse
I we're arguing one against one here is
his russell westbrook one of the
greatest athletes to ever play the game
yes he is I'll give you that is he one
of the greatest basketball players I
guess he's not better than Rick Barry
this doesn't have anything to do with oh
look at that physical specimen
I'm sure he's right better than john
havelcheck your beloved boston celtics
there who would you rather have russell
westbrook or john havelcheck I mean you
just depends on what you're done their
careers it's hard their careers okay
they don't but my arguments is based on
Championships and by the way John
Havlicek pretty good selection of
teammates yet around him for most of his
career like that was a great team that
he was a part of Westbrook had James
Harden and Kevin Durant and they didn't
want to stay in Oklahoma City well I
mean we can split hairs on like the
heart like heart mean you really want to
go back to harden like of course he at
the time he wanted to say you want to
get paid and privately Oklahoma City
officials will tell you that was the
biggest mistake that they made not
maxing out to harden and going into the
luxury tax that year they offered him
that was a caddis
to deny we're getting off track here
because real quick like you know
accomplishment there was a time when
averaging the triple-double was like Joe
DiMaggio hitting streak like there was a
time when nobody was going to do what
Oscar Robertson did and then Russell
Westbrook comes along and does it three
times like that definitely that's an
incredible accomplishment he's the most
ball dominant player of all time now him
and him and Harden the most bald
are you trying to tell me if magic
wanted averaged a triple-double if bird
wanted averaged a triple-double like
today's player is about stats it's about
look at what I'm doing they didn't magic
and bird didn't give a damn are you
trying to Braun is not averaging a
triple-double do you really think Larry
Bird went eight how many assists do I
need for a triple-double come on I think
but you don't think this is your Dan
across LeBrons mind averaged
triple-double
you don't think easily
the league in assists as the game stock
is over 10 per game no no I think it's I
think it's leading the league in assists
I think that was important for him
absolutely but are you trying to tell me
LeBron couldn't average a triple-double
every single year he hasn't like you
think you haven't tried it like you
don't think this man is mine ever come
on let's get real like of course like
LeBron like LeBrons the guy that's been
sleeping at not winning MVPs over the
year I've talked to Laker teammates I
wrote a story about as a month ago I
asked them like the MVP matter LeBron
Eric to a man they all say it's cool
accomplishments and accolades yeah they
do of course you want to win an MVP I
can understand that at his age yes
absolutely I understand that that's no
big secret I don't know why why am i
yelling it there though you're gonna sit
there though Dan and call look I agree
Russell Westbrook is wall dominant but
like he did spend most of his career
playing with Kevin Durant and that's
another ball dominant players right it's
not like he hit that one year or a
couple years where he had to do
literally everything beyond that he did
have to share responsibility with top
level players including this possible
just look at what Rick Barry did when he
won the title look at it look at his
scoring days that he had when he was in
the ABA and the NBA he was one of the
great passers of all time Russell
Westbrook can't pass when he can he's a
bull dominant player he's a one of the
top three of all time look at the
numbers ball dominant you got to do
stuff with it where does where does Kobe
Iraq on that list of all dominant
players where does Michael rank on that
list of all dominant players not like
Russell was he on not Mike Lee not like
Westbrook but let's not pretend as Grand
Canyon class gap between these players
at ball dominance you would rather have
Kobe over Russell Westbrook you rather
have Mike over Russell Westbrook I mean
come on yeah I don't want this to be
about Russell Westbrook I but I'm just
saying he won he won okay
so didn't Weddington got three
championships great like I mean really
really that's your comeback you're
better than that
Casey
Barry's better Russell
because one it doesn't have a point
Russell Westbrook on the teams that Rick
Barry at Rick Barry isn't better a
better player in my opinion that's all
it's just my opinion you see I've seen
the guys on the list all right name I
didn't see Mike and play and I didn't
see Bill Russell play I've seen them all
and I can make an educated assessment of
what I see with their games Rick Barry
was a spectacular player I'll leave it
at that
and sorry if I hurt your feelings with
Russell Westbrook Chinese the third who
is you know gonna win a title I'm sure
with the Rockets this year by the way
does the team that wins the title this
year get an asterisk by their name not
if there are not at the playoff format
stays the same and that was a take away
from the Friday call with the players
that the NBA wanted to have a
best-of-seven beginning with round one I
understand
it'll be in a neutral location I
understand it'll be different but if you
maintain the integrity of the playoff
lengths no there's no asset no more than
there will be an asterisk in the 99 2000
sees or any of the work stop experience
yeah all right
I met I think the season has the
asterisk the team's shouldn't be saddled
with an asterisk it's a level playing
field for everybody here like it or not
and and I agree hey we agreed on
something there now the likelihood of
basketball returning with what happened
with the Commissioner with this phone
call was there an informal poll that was
taken about coming back so give us some
details here on what's true and what's
not
yeah I mean well look uh everything's
true that you mentioned there have been
player representatives that have been
informally polling players via text
message to ask them if they wanted to
continue with the season now I talked to
several players about this who basically
said it's not as simple as yes or no I
mean there's there's variables here
there's you know what do you do with a
positive test what does the season look
like where are we playing like if you
are in a fundamental way yes everybody
wants
finish the season like for no other
reason they want to get paid like and
that's the biggest part of all this but
it was a strange poll to put out without
having all the variables accounted for I
would said this the other interesting
piece of news is I don't think it's
getting enough attention is that the NBA
in select cities is allowing for a
symptomatic testing and that to me is a
significant moving of the goalposts on
where the NBA initially what they were
telling me privately and other people
privately was where they they thought
they needed to be in order to start the
season like they thought they this one
he was like we have to have testing
that's just why develop a systematic
testing for whoever wants base you can
walk into a CVS and get tested
symptomatic or not we're clearly not
there yet but for the NBA to tell I
think it's Orlando when the two hours
I'm sure it's gonna be many more in the
days and weeks to come but for them to
say asymptomatic testings okay right now
in this current climate that tells me
that they're changing that criteria or
for what it needs to be when they come
back I'm also wondering how far can they
go into the calendar year here Chris
with you know how long do they stretch
it out before it affects next season
it's another good point because that's
another probably the one a takeaway I
had in the last four or five days from
these calls and and an information that
that's coming out it's abundantly clear
that the NBA and their owners don't give
a damn but when they start next season
and if that's the case you can keep
kicking the can down the road and you
know there was a report and and I
haven't talked anyway this morning about
it yet about beautiful weeks they'll
make a decision that that the ultimate
artificial deadline I mean if in two to
four weeks they're not ready to make a
decision if they don't care when next
season starts and for obvious reasons
crowds whatever they really don't they
can say well we're going to push to
mid-july and even like August like I
have some players that firmly believe
that they'll go into mid to late October
with a season if they have to get it
done so with that knowledge in hand
that's what makes me you know even
stronger today I did last week that
we'll find a way to finish the season I
didn't even get to the Jordan
documentary and we wasted all this time
on the greatness of Rick Barry yeah
greatness of Russell Westbrook you know
what I know you're not doing anything
you're quarantined probably in Vermont
why don't you do some research on Rick
Barry and then you come back with a book
right now
I apologize not being chronologically
old enough to have seen Rick Barry
playing like my bad you know what why
don't you be older Kris
good to talk to you okay thank you
that's Chris Mannix we're chillest rated
senior writer